bonjour christophe sira merci d'être
avec nous sur acta sur arte france bon
votre avis sur cette nouvelle tâche
attribués aux professionnels de la
restauration
est ce que c'est le rôle du restaurateur
non bien évidemment c'est pas le rôle du
restaurateur c'est à dire que on est
dans le toujours plus de toujours plus
en nous stigmatisent depuis bientôt deux
ans ça commence à bien faire c'est à
dire qu'on a un gouvernement qui
manifestement se déchargent bien
volontiers sur nous plutôt que d'assumer
ses propres turpitudes voilà où on en
est donc on est qu'est ce qu'on va nous
demander encore en deux depuis le temps
qu'on nous demande de faire des choses
qu'est ce qu'on va nous demander encore
c'est à dire que c'est sans fin donc il
faut qu'on il faut siffler la fin de
cette folie et revenir à des choses
normales et à des choses raisonnables
à travers ces annonces est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que
d'une certaine façon le gouvernement se
dédouane
bien sûr c'est à dire qu'il se disait
déchargent totalement sa responsabilité
dans cette gestion de crise que je vais
pas commenter ici mais en fait tout le
monde a bien compris que c'était pas un
merveilleux ou qui se décharge de la
responsabilité sur son nouveau commerce
parce que il n'ya pas que les
restaurants qui souffrent et puis alors
sur les non-vaccinés ma foi c'est sans
quoi un autre débat mais il ya un moment
où il va falloir qu'ils arrêtent de
trouver des alibis parce que les alibis
tiennent plus et tout le monde s'en rend
compte nous ça nous est vraiment très
très en colère parce qu'on est des
otages de 7,2 du fait qu'ils n'assument
pas leurs responsabilités
on est vraiment pris instrumentaliser
complètement se dire que c'est une
ingérence on a monté nos affaires avec
notre argent c'est des entreprises
privées et depuis le mois d'août on ou
non nous on nous impose on est
instrumentalisé avec ce pass sanitaire
déjà qui pour tout le monde a reconnu
qu'il n'était pas sanitaires c'est un
base pour forcer les gens les faire
vacciner on a été les objets les
instruments de cette politique personne
n'a réagi une fédération que syndicat ne
réagit à ce scandale on a déjà perdu
beaucoup de chiffre d'affaires à cause
de ça et on continue et on continue avec
toujours plus de contraintes mais
jusqu'où aller jusqu'où pourrait
accepter ça vous croyez que justement
c'est telle demande est là elle pourrait
être liée à la proche d'une hans
électorale importante la présidentielle
on sait que demander aux policiers de
d'effectuer des contrôles d'identité
pour lutter contre les faux pas
sanitaire ça peut être mal perçu par
la population
aux policiers aux restaurateurs le cvu
les policiers à la limite c'est leur
boulot justement c'est le sens de ma
question justement mais bien sûr alors
que nous c'était absolument pas notre
travail so lu ment pas dire qu'on monte
les gens les gens les uns contre les
autres c'est classique depuis le début
de cette crise voilà donc qu'est ce qui
va se passer on va provoquer des
bagarres à l'entraidé des restaurants on
peut cliquer légitimité au mais avant
tout ça qu'est ce qu'on a je veux dire
honnêtement qu'est ce qu'on en a à
[ __ ] dans ce problème dans ce débat
voilà on n'a rien à faire dans cette
histoire encore une fois on est les
objets d'une politique on est des
pantins j'en ai utilisé et on n'a rien à
faire dans tout ça on n'a rien à
contrôler ses de ces débiles ben si ça
fonctionnait ça se saurait ce pas si
l'épave il est pas sanitaires tout le
monde la reconnaît y compris les plus
hauts des membres du gouvernement
stop on arrête quand il s'agit de faire
du sanitaire on est les premiers et
aucun problème en a on n'a pas du tout
envie ni d'être malade nick nos clients
sont malades on a envie de les revoir on
n'a aucun problème avec ça mais qu'on
arrête de nous instrumentaliser très
honnêtement je pense qu'on va finir par
vraiment se fâcher
avec ça le durcissement des des
restrictions dans quelle mesure votre
profession elle est pénalisée
on en arrive là c'est à dire qu'on a
déjà perdu du chiffre d'affaires à
partir du mois d'août et l'instauration
tu passes sanitaire en continuant perdre
énormément depuis les annonces de jean
castex qui est formidable premier
ministre qui explique alors confère la
discothèque ce qui n'a aucun sens mais
que l'est le reste reste ouvert mais qui
ne faut surtout pas aller dans les
endroits où manger ou en bois ce qui
fait comme ça tout le monde a résilié
ces réservations on perd le 50 à 80 90 %
de nos réservations les traiteurs c'est
la même chose pour l'événementiel est
sinistrée on aurait pendant ce temps
bruno le maire qui nous dit que tout va
bien et que il va faire des aides à
partir de jeux probable 50% perte de
chiffre d'affaires c'est à dire que si
monsieur le maire en cours on lui
enlèverait moitié de son salaire et
qu'on lui dit on va juste de rembourser
ton forfait téléphonique je sais pas si
ça va lui plaire beaucoup à lyon on en
est passé
c'est dramatique mais bien sûr que la
profession et est fortement touchée et
on va obligatoirement réagir c'est on
peut pas rester comme ça alors vous
savez que pour les défenseurs justement
des du pass sanitaire voilà c'est aussi
ça peut être perçu comme une solution
pour les restaurateurs pas seulement
pour les restaurateurs afin de permettre
justement lanouf fermeture des lieux
publics
dans cette période de pandémie
bien sûr c'est à dire qu'on ferme pas
les lieux publics et en expérience
indique aux gens ne surtout pas y aller
c'est formidable comme démarche c'est à
dire qu'on livre on assassine les
commerces on est d'accord avec ça c'est
à dire que les sous verre et on les
laisse crever et vous craignez vous
craignez christophe cherrad de nouvelles
mesures comme un couvre feu dont on
parle actuellement des jauges et voire
peut-être une fermeture avec variées aux
migrants qui est un canal qui inquiète
la planète
avec ce gouvernement tout tout est à
craindre au plus rien nous surprend
c'est à dire que et ce n'est rien au
micron tout le monde est en train de
s'apercevoir que il est finalement
absolument pas dangereux
alors je sais pas
à quoi ça sert on n'a pas vraiment
encore toutes les informations mais il
est très contagieuse selon les
conclusions en tout cas de l'om est à
présent bien sûr et bien sûr mais on
voit bien dans les pays où il a été
détecté avant la france et notamment en
afrique du sud par exemple c'est je
crois que les hospitalisations ont été
divisés par 80% donc
où est le problème est alors qu'en plus
ils ont pas une grande couverture
vaccinale onglets ont préféré peut-être
eu le l'humanité naturel que de la
vaccination forcée mais c'est encore un
autre débat mais pourquoi craindre
quelque chose qui n'est pas dangereux
mais on marche sur la tête véritablement
c'est faux il faut il faut reprendre
raison à tous les niveaux ce calme et
vivre et quand on vit on est bien on vit
quand on est vivant normalement oui
merci à vous à christophe girard avoir
réagi en dur sur notre antenne rappelle
que vous êtes un restaurateur
vice-président du syndicat antigone oui
tout le monde peut nous rejoindre sur le
site merci à vous